un sociólogo sospechan que los hombres
son más propensos a recibir una multa
por exceso de velocidad que las mujeres
el sociólogo quiere tomar una muestra y
crear un intervalo z de dos muestras en
otros vídeos ya hemos hablado de esta
idea crear un intervalo z de dos
muestras para estimar la diferencia
entre la proporción de hombres que han
recibido una multa y la proporción de
mujeres que también la han recibido
cuáles de las siguientes opciones son
condiciones para este tipo de intervalo
escoge todas las que apliquen como
siempre pausa el vídeo e intenta
responder por tu cuenta
muy bien revisemos las condiciones que
se deben de cumplir para la inferencia
primero tenemos la condición de
aleatoriedad
y esta es la misma de la que hablamos
cuando trabajamos con una sola muestra
pero ahora tenemos que estar seguro de
que se aplica a ambas muestras es decir
a ambas muestras deben de estar
seleccionadas de una manera aleatoria la
segunda es la condición de normalidad y
ésta nos dice que la distribución
muestral de proporciones para cada una
de las muestras es aproximadamente
normal así que lo que tienes que hacer
es tomar el tamaño de la primera muestra
y multiplicarlo por la proporción
muestral de la primera muestra y esto
debe de ser mayor o igual a 10 también
multiplicas el tamaño de la primera
muestra por 1 - la proporción muestral
de la primera muestra y eso debe de ser
mayor o igual a 10
otra forma de pensarlo es el número de
éxitos y fracasos esperados en la
primera muestra debe de ser mayor o
igual a 10
y después hacer lo mismo para la segunda
muestra multiplicar el tamaño de la
segunda muestra ojo no forzosamente
deben de ser del mismo tamaño por la
proporción muestral de la segunda
muestra y esto debe de ser mayor o igual
a 10 y también al multiplicar el tamaño
de la segunda muestra por uno menos la
proporción muestral de la segunda
muestra también debe de ser mayor o
igual a 10 todo esto se debe de cumplir
y la última es la condición de
independencia y éstas se satisfacen si
las observaciones individuales en estas
muestras se hacen cuando en plazo o
incluso si no se hacen con reemplazo
pero si las muestras no son más del 10%
de la población entonces se satisface la
condición de independencia una vez más
todo esto lo hemos visto antes solo que
esta vez lo estamos haciendo con dos
muestras así que veamos
cuál es las siguientes opciones son
condiciones para este tipo de intervalo
escoge todas las que apliquen ok la
primera dice lo siguiente las muestras
incluyen al menos 10 personas que han
recibido una multa por exceso de
velocidad y al menos 10 personas que no
si esto es cierto esto es lo mismo que
cumplir la condición de normalidad
puedes ver esta primera parte como el
número esperado de personas que ha
recibido una multa no por exceso de
velocidad y esta otra como el número
esperado de personas que no ha recibido
una multa aquí estamos usando la
proporción muestral no la verdadera
proporción así que esto debe de ser
mayor o igual a 10 y por lo tanto esto
es completamente cierto
inciso b las personas seleccionadas en
cada muestra se pueden considerar
independientes claro tenemos la
condición de independencia o las
personas son mostradas con reemplazo o
se están mostrando menos del 10% de la
población así que esto es importante
voy a seleccionarlo
y la última pero no menos importante se
toman muestras aleatorias separadas de
hombres y mujeres si esta es la
condición de aleatoriedad que nos piden
aquí por lo tanto tenemos las tres
condiciones de este ejercicio tenemos la
condición de normalidad la condición de
independencia y la condición de
aleatoriedad
hagamos otro ejemplo dice un grupo de
biólogos está estudiando una cierta
enfermedad que afecta a los robles de un
bosque ellos tienen la curiosidad de
saber si existen una diferencia entre la
proporción de árboles infectados en la
sección norte y sur del bosque quieren
tomar una muestra de árboles de cada
sección y realizar una prueba z de dos
muestras para probar sus hipótesis
cuáles de las siguientes opciones son
condiciones para este tipo de prueba
elige todas las que apliquen y de nuevo
pausa el vídeo e intenta responder bueno
ya revisamos las condiciones que se
deben de cumplir así que veamos cuáles
de estas son las condiciones para la
inferencia la primera opción dice ambas
muestras incluyen al menos 30 árboles
bueno esta opción podría ser tentadora
porque aparece el número 30 este es un
número que aparece al pensar acerca de
las condiciones para la inferencia
cuando tratamos con medias pero no
aparece cuando hablamos de proporción
no es necesario que ambas muestras deban
incluir al menos 30 árboles por lo tanto
esta no es una de nuestras opciones
correctas muestrean el mismo número de
árboles para cada región del bosque este
es un error típico de una idea
equivocada que cuando realizas una
prueba zeta de dos muestras o cuando
realizas un intervalo z de dos muestras
o un intervalo de confianza ambas
muestras deben de tener el mismo tamaño
pero eso no es cierto por lo tanto
también cancelar esta idea
observan al menos 10 árboles con la
enfermedad y al menos 10 árboles sin la
enfermedad en cada muestra si esa es la
condición de normalidad que acabamos de
ver así que esta es la única opción
correcta que seleccionaremos en este
ejercicio y terminamos nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo